on the mound for the padres joe musgrove
28 year old making his sixth start
and among the major league pitchers joe
ranks second an opponent batting average
at 137
3-2 is into the shift over to cover his
muskrat throw his eye
and pulls him off the bag
throw coming from cronenworth who threw
it while he was on the move towards the
line
joe musgrove covering does he keep his
foot on the bag when the ball
is in the glove oh this will be good
here watch when the ball hits the glove
there and he's out i got out he is
and we got out at first base nicely done
two two is in the air to right center
field struck pretty well pro fart going
back onto the track
he dives and makes the catch jerks and
pro far
on the dirt of the track in right center
makes the catch
yeah tip your cap to the crowd you
betcha you deserve it jerkson
talkman can't believe it somebody call
the cops
because that's highway robbery right
there right-hander kevin gausman who has
been spectacular this year
he's a seven year veteran 30 years old
one down here in the first inning brings
up fernando tatis jr
fly ball deep right field down the line
towards the corner
and the pole and it is gone home run for
fernando tatis junior
this is a skyscraper gets into the
first couple rows in right field and
fernando tatis jr picks up his eighth
home run of the year
and the padres take the one-nothing lead
fernando says i want to go sit out on
the porch
i'm going to go opposite field here and
do a little porch action
nothing padres says brandon belt will
lead it off here for the giants in the
second inning
and he will strike out looking who's
ready to toss the bat
head on down to first but cb buckner has
other ideas
for a strikeout for joe musgrove on the
day
and i think he went he did he strikes
out
so de bond becomes strikeout victim
number two for joe musgrove two down
tough to lay off we've seen it many many
times this season with joe musgrove
that slider it's the go-to
swing and a miss and musgrove able to
strike out the side gets dugger
two on nobody out one nothing padres but
the giants are threatening
so here's tommy lestella stella hits a
fly ball
shallow left sprinting over it's going
to drop and that is a
fair ball just inside the line casale
read it well coming around third
and he's going to score the giants tie
the game on a little blue pit down the
left field line
so the leadoff walk to the eighth place
hitter is turned into a run
you're at the top of the order still
nobody out
hammered to right dave
a line drive home run mike talkman
that was a shot the giants have made it
a big inning still
nobody out and now four runs in they
lead the padres
four to one and that's a three run home
run and it's four to one
and that's the hit they've been looking
for for three days
first home run for mike tuckman in a
giant uniform
one out and cronenworth comes up
cronenworth struck out in the second
inning
he drives one to left dickerson coming
in and he makes the catch
grandpa on his belly two down oh and
that's a one pitch out
and kevin gausman appreciates the effort
so here is
caratini here's his pitch splitter
struck him out swinging
guaranteed chased it that was just
beautifully thrown
and gosman uses the strikeout to get out
of the jam
kevin gausman is going to leave things
off
face it for guzman well that his first
of the year
the stella now now a swing and there's a
line drive into left center field that's
a base hit
racing back into his right is the center
field of grisham and it's off his glove
and rolls away
fam over to pick it up racing around
third grossman heading home
and he will score and into third is
tommy lestella
and it is five to one giants
they got stella at third base with
nobody out here in the fifth inning
flores now the infield in
on the ground to short tatis from his
knees
fires to first for the out and coming in
to score from third is la stella
and he earned himself coming in pulled
up blame something
by the way nice play by fernando tatties
junior going up the middle one of the
better defensive plays we've seen to
make this year
we have steven duggar there's a ground
to right side
diving is conor worth to able to make
the play nicely done by jake cronenworth
laying it out he flips to tatis and they
force out dubon in second base
2-1 down to third nicely picked by
machado
gets up and throws him out across the
diamond manny machado down there at
third base if you didn't know
where is it first base and brandon bell
coming up in his fourth plate appearance
today
striking out a lot lately and twice in
this game today
looking in the second swinging in the
third before he flied out to left field
in the fifth inning
the ground ball to second base could be
two second from juan matado to first for
two
six five three on the dp no problem with
the slick baseball that's for sure
kick of the bag from manny over to
hosmer
so three straight walks the bases are
loaded for
austin slater now grounds went down to
third base machado's coming home for one
and that's all they'll get but they get
the lead runner
swing and a miss and down goes longoria
[Applause]
needed that strike shot longoria two
down in the ninth inning
and enjoy a 6-1 lead right now they've
got the bases loaded with two down in
the ninth inning
they'll all be running there they go the
pitch way outside the fourth walk of the
inning
that forces home a run seven to one
giants
the giants three outs away from getting
a win in this series before heading to
colorado camilo doval who had a tough
night last night although
the final line probably looked worse
than he actually pitched
and a little pop-up
and it'll be devon and that's the ball
game
so the giants do indeed win one game in
this three-game series
it's significant because that evens up
the overall series